I'd like to go over a list of areas
that require attention some of this will
be no news to you some of it perhaps
toxic disposal
we don't have a theory of toxic disposal
what we have is a theory of toxic hiding
Shell Games
postponement tabling we need a real
method of toxic disposal until it comes
we continue to sequester radioactive and
toxic materials throughout the world in
the body of the earth many of these
toxic materials have half-lives of
hundreds of thousands of years again
yesterday's newspaper Greenpeace
reported encountering a Soviet frigate
in the Sea of Japan dumping nuclear
cores and nuclear coolant into the Sea
of Japan where the Japanese population
draws 30 percent of its C catch
we need toxic disposal plants have a
role to play here many of you know that
the solanaceous plants like the Jimson
weed and the datura sequester heavy
metals but these this information has
not been made the centerpiece of a crash
program to clean up the land simply
because people do not care enough or
rather human institutions read
corporations do not care enough
environmental restoration another area
where tiny pilot projects are held up in
such a fashion to give people permission
to think well that's under control at
least we don't have to worry about that
most of the restoration programs that
you hear about are in fact cosmetic
efforts designed to divert your
attention from some greater horror being
perpetuated somewhere else
you have to be very sophisticated
because the enemy you're playing with is
incredibly sophisticated
we need Planet friendly Technologies an
obvious one is hydrogen hydrogen when
burned in an automobile or a boiler
combines uh uh with oxygen to produce
water
it is a technology that is non-polluting
and by developing liquid natural gas
storage and transportation Technologies
we have proven that we can handle
hydrogen hydrogen is highly explosive
but if you blow up a hydrogen loading or
unloading Depot all you have is a very
violent localized explosion you don't
have planetary contamination of the
water and the air hydrogen is the
direction in which we should be moving
and the people who have studied it have
put in place all kinds of technological
schemes for bringing it to us but the
problem is that those who are already
peddling natural gas and petroleum
byproducts are not interested in this
scheme their loyalty then is not to the
species or to the planet but the bottom
line in any civilized society putting
the bottom line ahead of civilization
and Planet would be a hanging offense
but not here
another area
population control
this is one that everyone agrees with
but the facts of the matter have not I
think been fully explored a child born
to a woman in San Francisco or Malibu
will consume between 800 and a thousand
times the natural resources of a child
born to a woman in Bangladesh where do
we preach birth control that's right
Bangladesh
the women who could make the notice that
if every woman had one child
the population of this planet would fall
by 50 percent in one generation
now without War without famine without
displacement of populations the
population of the planet would fall by
half in the lifetime of most people
sitting here I don't think people
realize this we tend to assume the
population problem is Unstoppable uh
the women most likely to hear the
message that one woman one child leads
to a saner world are the Highly Educated
women of the high-tech industrial
democracies the kind of women sitting in
this room since their children are using
800 to a thousand times more resources
than the children of the third world if
10 to 15 percent of the women in the
high-tech industrial democracies were to
follow this policy the release
of pressure on World Resources would be
visible within 10 to 15 years now I
realize these suggestions are highly
controversial and I have a number of
them so I don't want to we could hold a
whole conference on that concept
the other thing another item we need to
deconstruct product fetishism we need to
through the media establish the idea
that a zen-like spareness
is the highest expression of social
Consciousness when it comes to interior
decorating
the building of country houses and so
forth and so on deconstruct product
fetishism so that the the kikuyu
or the yanomama become the paragons
of behavior in terms of relating to
material existence we do not need to
sell our souls to junk
and then inherit a ruined Planet it
makes no sense at all this is a problem
because the techniques of capitalism are
to use advertising to spread discontent
they are selling you something you don't
already have discontent is the obvious
way to move you to make that purchase so
you're constantly being bombarded with
images of your own inadequacy unless you
have the correct running shoes German
automobile or a house in the country
next item
demilitarization
there there is much talk about getting
rid of nuclear weapons because the
leadership of these bankrupt fascist
oligarchies could themselves be
incinerated by nuclear weapons but where
is the lantern jawed lab from Alabama on
the subject of getting rid of all armies
on this planet now is the moment because
there are not large crystallized power
blocks set against each other how about
a 15 reduction in all military budgets
across the board no one can claim that
their security is lessened because
they're enemies too would reduce
military spending apparently there's a
big game going on dealing all this
lethal junk all over the world and
that's why there's no mention of
demilitarizing even such regimes as the
Haitian or the Somalian regime it is
apparently a natural right of Dominator
jerks to have as much Weaponry as they
can buy with the money they steal and
squeeze out of their captive population
another area democratic values and human
rights
democratic values and human rights you
cannot build an echo Consciousness out
of a population of slaves ruled by
oligarchs and that is the situation for
one-third of the human species so long
as the octogenarian trash that rules
China is in place where is our
government on that issue and that leads
me to government accountability
are we making our governments
accountable
in the matter of preserving the
environment cleaning up toxic waste
disposing of the manufacturing processes
of these oh so necessary weapons
stockpiles that these characters feel
they have have to have
well that's a pretty
um nuts and bolts laundry list not the
sort of thing you're used to hearing
from me uh
I think hearing a list like that the
senses may be great list but uh it's a
little overwhelming in the demands that
it makes how are we to fulfill these
many agendas at once and this is where
we come to my bailiwick
it is less than a hundred years
since the great stabilizing and
Illuminating force in the lives of
archaic people
has come to the attention of Western
Civilization the great stabilizing and
Illuminating force in the lives of
archaic people
is there a vegetable connection
to the guy in mind their ability to to
experientially not abstract reasoning
like I've been doing here to
experientially feel
the planet
our mother its needs its tensions where
it is in pain they do this through the
ingestion of psychoactive plants
they did this through the ingestion of
psychoactive plants for 50 to 100
000 years before the uh excrementally
brained monotheist agriculturalist
faction arose
the greatest gift of the vegetable mind
to the human order is the Psychedelic
experience
because it allows the dissolution of
boundaries
and it is going to be necessary to
dissolve those boundaries in order to
coordinate the metamorphosis of the
human world we have to have a vision I
don't mean a plan I don't mean an agenda
I mean a vision
the vision comes from above it comes
from call it the unconscious call it the
guy in mind call it the great spirit it
doesn't come out of committee meetings
and the data gathered by statistical
analysis we lack at the highest level
not you and not me but at the
controlling level we lack a vision the
best leaders Among Us are no more than
crisis managers attempting to manage us
past an apocalypse that they are coming
to believe is inevitable that isn't good
enough that's not what my daddy raised
me for and it's not what your daddy
raised you for we represent The Cutting
Edge of novelty in the biological World
our self-reflective Consciousness is our
great Glory it also opens for us a
dimension of moral responsibility
unknown to the rest of the denizens of
nature part of our Promethean and
Godlike aspiration to the control of
nature is the concomitant obligation
to care for nature and to feel
so really my my message here is a
message of feeling the ideas will come
the rasiosa nation will come but what we
have to do is feel our dilemma
if we could feel our dilemma and make
other people feel our dilemma we would
move rapidly toward real solutions we
are anesthetized we are a world dying
under anesthesia for lack of authentic
experience authentic connection with the
Living World out of which we came if we
can do this by whatever techniques are
available if we can create a sense of
community
globally then attending that sense of
community will be a sense of caring and
responsibility it cannot happen unless
we change our minds we have
Technologies
money the logistical ability to do
almost anything in the human world but
we don't know how to change our minds we
are angels with a Siamese twin who is a
monkey growing out of our chest and this
was all very fine when there were
endless environments to dispoil and vast
herds of game that curious amalgam of
the animal and the Angelic that is our
humanness could exist in that kind of an
environment but no more and for the past
Thousand Years the moral
bankruptcy of Western Civilization has
become more and more apparent the
chickens are coming home to roost we
must build community and we must do it
in a short time we've lost our Compass
we don't know who we are we don't know
where we want to go we are our own lives
are an experience of of inadequacy and
tension we have lost our Compass but
it's there and not because the
psychedelics are a magical Panacea the
psychedelics lift the veil on the
intention of the guy in mind and we are
but atoms in that guy in mind if we do
not follow its purpose we have no
purpose who do we think we are Western
science is 600 years old human beings
have been on this planet two million
years life 1.4 billion years there is an
enormous wisdom in biology and we must
become
able to tap into that articulate it and
then activate it we are the crowning
achievement of The evolutionary process
let's not try it let's make it the
ascent to Angelic being that is I am
sure the intention of the guy in mind
and all the rest of the life with which
we share this planet thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]